في قضيه حكيمي في شخص ثاني من اول القصه
الانظار متوجهه له وفي انتظار رده فعله
ممرضه ولوالدته وانما زميله في النادي
باريس سان جيرمان
وصديقه المقرب الفرنسي كيليان مبابي
الاثنين معروفين انه بتجمعهم علاقه شخصيه
قويه جدا وصداقه بتتعدى مجرد الزماله في
المهنه او في النادي والناس بتستنى تشوف
اي رده فعل من مبابي وفجاه ملت المنصات
تغريده وخبر انه يهدد الاتحاد الفرنسي
لكره القدم انه راح يعتزل دوليا اذا ما
ثبتت براءه صديقه حكيمي وهذا الخبر كان
متداول ومنسوب لمحطه تي في سانك الفرنسيه
الشهيره وبيقول انه هدد بالاعتزال دوليا
في حال وقع ظلم بحق حكيمي وانه طلب من
نادي باريس سان جيرمان واللاعبين يساندوه
في المحنه اللي بيمر فيها في ناس صدقت
وبدات تمدح في مبابي الصديق الوفي وناس
تانيه تنتقل تقول
[موسيقى]